what happens in Vegas I'm asking the
question what happens is that I don't
I think the theme of today's shoot
really comes down to the notion of it's
not funny anymore when is something no
longer funny and you know kind of
connecting into some of the comedy that
I've done like you got to push it to the
edge but when does it go overboard and
so the shoot today I think ended up
being all things that take it overboard
it's when it's gone too far and it's
just not funny anymore
Steven had me taped up to a pole about
eight feet in the air with duct tape and
just hanging there I had my face all
bloodied and battered while wearing a
perfect suit and then we had sort of
like clown makeup on my face and then me
making fun of somebody while wearing the
clown makeup so not your typical
photoshoot I think that band param was
pretty cool and I saw John there play
live recently which was pretty
exceptional that cat Raiden Josh Raiden
his new album is pretty interesting I
like the new Jack Johnson album I think
that's pretty cool I've been you know
it's weird I've been listening to a lot
of like Mike and this is an influence
for my kids for sure that a lot of Daft
Punk lately they reminded me of when I
used to go to raves when I was younger
and it's a that was a good that's so
I've been like listening a little bit
more Daft Punk lately
being on TV makes people feel like they
really know you like really know you
right because they've hung it like any
time you've got something they sat in
their underwear
and they hung out on their couch eating
some potato chips and they were hanging
out with you they feel really
comfortable with you right so some of
the like the craziest thing is when
someone comes up to you tells you
something really personal and you're
like I don't even know if you man like
what I get like and you want to help but
it's like you just kind of her like wow
I'm holding this big weird shaped
emotional issue I always wanted to Punk
the president like I really did and
there was a couple times where I thought
we're gonna have a shot at it but it's
just too protective you know like the
Secret Service and the whole thing like
you it's just it's too much like shoe
leather to get through you can't get to
the guy go and just stand in front of a
McDonald's and ask people walking by
where McDonald's is and just see how
they look at you and see and like so if
you could do that then when you look
stupid in everyday life you've already
gone through it so it's not a big deal